right now we're joined by chris mannix
from sports illustrated somebody i have
lectured with
at the university of southern california
and uh professor mannix joins us right
now are you in milwaukee are you in the
deer district
i'm not in milwaukee i was uh on usa
basketball duty
the last week in las vegas so uh
spent my time watching the finals on tv
chris mannix the season pro
the las vegas assignment or the
milwaukee assignment chooses vegas
uh we appreciate you taking some time uh
the nba finals roll on tonight though
game six and besides chris paul's
interaction with scott foster
maybe switching it up in the pre-game
maybe a little nod in a wink as opposed
to a scowl and a glare
but what else can phoenix do to switch
things up to try to get this series back
to a game seven
well you know their their defensive
struggles
have been maybe the most perplexing over
the last three games this team came
in to these finals playing the second
best defense in the playoffs right
behind milwaukee
and if you look at the numbers you know
half court transition
whatever they've just collapsed over
these last few games
some of that i think can be attributed
to deandre ayton just being stretched
way too long in these games i mean an
underrated
aspect or variable in these finals
is the dario sarat injury and that that
injury
limited monty williams to really eight
guys because he doesn't trust frank
kaminsky and
so and you see ayton out there i think
it was 39 minutes in game three
45 in game five he's having to play
a lot of minutes and i think they have
to find a way in this game even if it's
even if it it's potentially hurt uh
hurtful in the short term
of getting him out of there and and
playing somebody be a kaminsky or
somebody else
to just make sure ayton is fresh for
that fourth quarter so
that to me is you know chris paul is the
obvious guy to watch you know does he
play better against us through holiday
defense but
for me ayton and that sons defense is is
the biggest question
chris the biggest question we had in the
studio was uh
how did the guy who was counting money
make his money in the stands uh did he
how did he get the money in his pocket
that night how much money did he have
uh one of the great moments of the nba
finals was that
the money shot uh talk to me a little
bit about some of the other great
moments
in the finals and where they are
historically in terms of
you know giannis's block and just sort
of the coronation of giannis
and this performance i i mean i think
the block
if the bucks finish off this series
tonight or game seven
will live in infamy i mean we remember
the lebron block in large part because
they won that series right like
if they had lost we probably wouldn't
remember it
as as strongly uh if the bucks closed
this out that block is going to be
replayed over and over again in the
pantheon
of those great finals moments because
just like lebron
there's probably not two or three
players in basketball that can do that
to both have the ability to step out on
a on a screener or on the roll and then
get back and block a shot of a seven
footer
at the rim so yeah that that to me is
just a signature moment y'all just had a
couple of course
um some big scoring nights early that
dunk at the end of game five but
you know that that block i say a couple
of guys could do it maybe there's nobody
that could do it i mean giannis is just
so genetically gifted and so skilled
defensively that
he might be the only player ever you
know to be able to pull that off
chris mannix joins the show the
crossover podcast and of course sports
illustrated
ben line's in for rich on the rich eisen
show let's play this out chris
phoenix loses tonight milwaukee wins
how does that impact chris paul's future
and where he might play next season
well people around chris paul have have
told me that
like they'd like to get something done
with phoenix now
you know this is probably chris's last
contract kind of amazing we're even
saying that since
two years ago we were talking about the
contract being an albatross around the
neck of whatever team
uh gets him but he's in line for three
year 100 million
ish contracts in his next deal they'll
take him right around 39 years old
uh and look there's you know chris
didn't just get traded to phoenix like
he
wanted to be there like he scouted that
situation he knew monty williams he
believed in devin booker so
i think there's a look he's he he still
lives in la so it's a short hop for him
to get there so
i think there's momentum to get a deal
done for around three years
one way or the other whether it's opting
in and extending opting out in a new
deal one way or the other
i think there's some momentum there the
wild card though
is robert sarver i mean you know that
that roster is going to get expensive
does robert sarver have it in him to
just say look we got to give this guy a
blank check whatever he wants
we've got to give him because if we
don't everything we've gained
over the last calendar year gets wiped
away i mean cameron payne's been
incredible but you don't want to go into
next season with cameron payne
as your starting point guard you need
chris paul to continue
to build on what they've accomplished
this season so
if i was a betting man i'd say it gets
done one way or the other but
starver who doesn't have a tremendous
track record uh he is a variable
chris you were just uh covering team usa
as they get ready for the
the olympics and we're going to see
three of the guys playing tonight
as part of team usa in a few weeks now
devin booker
chris middleton drew holiday as early as
next week
how do you think they blend in to what's
happening right now with team usa which
has been a roster in flux
and walk me through their schedules when
do we see them playing for team usa
if they're in the nba finals for another
few days well i talked to
greg popovich about this on sunday and
the expectation
is that they will arrive in tokyo
uh about a day before the first game so
i'm guessing sunday is when they're
likely to arrive
uh there uh you know nobody really knows
what to expect from these guys and i
asked pop that directly i said yeah i
mean
you've been on teams or coach teams that
have been to
the finals they've experienced a
grueling postseason you know what's left
in these guys
after it's done i mean what are you
expecting from booker middleton
and holiday and he's like i just don't
know man like i don't
i don't know what these guys are going
to be able to give i mean you know maybe
they come in
with some energy especially guys from
the team that won but
i think more likely than not they're
just gassed out and they're
you know they're going to play and
contribute but you're not going to get
the the final version of devin booker
and chris middleton
and true holiday so you know usa
basketball is counting on them because
their roster right now
is paper thin i mean zach levine is not
going to be there right away
we'll see how that works out jason tatum
battling a knee injury
they need those guys to to play for them
and play well but
i just i don't know what you're gonna
get from them after
uh this type of final that's why i think
this us team might be in a lot of
trouble when they get to tokyo
chris mannix joins the show sports
illustrated in the crossover podcast ben
lines in for rich this is the rich eisen
show
and it felt like on friday chris that
the damien lillard story was like
end of the end of the week news dump uh
let's uh put that out on a friday at the
end of the weekend there's nba finals
going on
people won't really pay attention to
that as much as maybe they should
just going to tokyo and and leaving the
country and having the games actually
start
do you think that brings some of the
attention away from the damian lillard
stuff or does that
add to it because he'll be on tv every
night well
no i think it'll take away and i think
it gives
everyone a chance to go to their neutral
corners
and figure out what to do next now i
don't know what came
of the meeting in vegas between damian
lillard
chauncey phillips and neil o'shea i
would imagine
that neil o'shea
you know directly asked dame if he was
in and
you know dame said this on the call with
reporters
what he says to media is basically the
same thing he says to
to the front office like he's not he's
not giving two different answers here so
what so his feelings
about that team are you are what we
heard
so i would expect in the next month
you're gonna see portland
try to do some things i don't know what
they can do they've got one great asset
in cj mccollum but everything else
it's it's not as valuable as maybe they
think so
i think you'll see them try to improve
the roster in the next month
and then come mid august when usa
basketball is over we'll see where they
are
in portland if they made the kind of
upgrades that lillard
needed to see in order for him to fully
commit to coming back to portland
you know chris there's something
interesting about this usa team and and
i don't
obviously uh i know it's an unusual
olympic cycle
uh obviously with the the way the nba
season
was scheduled and rolled out certain
guys were limited and weren't able to
participate but the idea that they
should be the favorite just because
they're america
seems rather ignorant to me i mean look
at basketball on a global scale
you've got giannis tonight a two-time
mvp
jokic the mvp this year luca is an
emerging star
in dallas the game's gone global so why
do you think the americans should even
feel
like they should should be the favor
just for showing up
well they they shouldn't and hopefully
they don't
because this us team is
not the a team by any stretch and even
if it was
you know these these games are just
different i mean we already saw
nigeria which has a handful of minor
nba players win against the us we saw
australia which
has nba players but if you put that team
in the nba they struggle to get
double-digit wins
you know plus the fever rules are so
different i asked ricky rubio
that like what are you noticing when you
know guys come to
international games for the first time
like many of these us players are and
it's like they struggle with physicality
they struggle with some of the rule
changes like the you know five seconds
in the lane and
uh the goaltending rules and some of the
other things you're allowed to do
it's just an adjustment so like you know
the the us team is always going to have
the biggest names no matter what group
they send
but this version of it you know if i had
to make a prediction i i don't
i wouldn't predict them to meddle i i
just wouldn't because
you know there there just are some
really good international teams going
you know spain
who you at the us played on sunday and
beat they're going to be good i mean the
gasal like
these teams have got players that have
been part of their
program for decades now and they're
familiar with each other i mean ricky
rubio
like fema ricky rubio is like a
different person like he is
he's not the nba player you know the
fans and
one of his many stops have grown to see
he's just a really really good
international player and so are many of
these guys so i just think this us team
with the team it's bringing over and the
fact that i don't believe that those
three guys
that are coming late are going to be
miracle workers i think they have to
work cut out for them just a medal
chris mannix joins the show sports
illustrated the crossover podcast ben
lion's in for rich this is the rich
eisen show
do you get a sense though from being
around team usa that despite not
you know you don't sound like you have
confidence in them to meddle however do
you
get a sense from being around the guys
that they understand the magnitude of
the moment that they understand just
what a privilege it is to be
representing team usa and considering
everything happening in the world the
fact that we even have an olympic games
and just sort of understanding where
their place in history and
and alongside some of the all-time
greats no i i think they do
and you know all these guys want to be
here and i give them a ton of credit for
you know jumping into the program with
the understanding that covid was going
to be an issue during training camp
and covet will be a big time issue when
they get over to tokyo their movements
are
going to be incredibly restricted making
the bubble look
you know almost free free by example you
know almost like it's
it's uh anything goes by example
um i don't think they're they're
overconfident at all i think they
understand
what their their duties are and they
want to do it it's just
chemistry matters and it's just
impossible
to get the kind of chemistry that you
need to beat
teams that have been playing together
for a generation i mean i'm
i'm watching like you know louis skoll i
think is still out there and yeah i mean
the gasal brothers rudy fernandez like
that that spanish team all those guys
were in their mid to late 30s
at this point powell hasn't played nba
basketball in two years but he's out
there playing for spain i mean
it's it's really it's just so difficult
to match the chemistry and
in these international competitions
chemistry is as important as talents
so overcome you know if the us team
gains chemistry on the fly in ways i
don't expect
they might win they might win big but if
they don't they could lose and they
could lose pretty early
chemistry also a thing with the nba
finals chris you know it's it's
interesting to me that in an age of
player mobility
you've got giannis and chris middleton
as the longest tenured bucks
on this team and the fact that brook
lopez has been there for a while now and
there's some
cohesion uh with this group do you think
that's a trend we'll see
with team building moving forward the
idea of really wanting to commit to your
guys for
an extended period of time developing
your program uh you're seeing it with
devin booker now
uh pretty soon the conversation's gonna
turn to around you know his free agency
or his future
how do you see the the impact of these
finals permeating throughout the league
in the next few years
well i mean teams especially small or
smaller market teams
want to keep their group together i mean
that's their
best chance to win knowing that they
can't lure stars in free agency the way
some of these bigger market teams so
you have seen and will continue to see
you know teams like phoenix and
milwaukee do everything they can
to retain the players they have in their
pipeline i don't want to overplay
chemistry though because
i think we'd all probably agree if the
brooklyn nets were fully healthy
they'd probably win that series i mean
that's the next team that was
thrown together on the fly with like 10
games together in the regular season and
a handful more
in the playoffs so talent still matters
in the nba
if you have superior talent you're
probably going to win a lot of these
series but for smaller market teams
you know you look up at milwaukee as an
example they've kept middleton
and giannis together they signed holiday
to a four-year deal so he's part of the
program
uh long-term you know their their goal
is to win
through these guys and they've done a
good job of doing it so far
chris mannix joins the show sports
illustrated of course the
crossover podcast ben line's in for rich
the rich eisen show
other stories uh around the world of nba
basketball right now is the status of
kawhi leonard
and chris if i if i'm kawhi
um i've got to be thinking about you
know my future
long term and looking for a long term
deal somewhere
signing a one or two year deal right now
or opting out or
you know i i don't know if i can have
the confidence in my health long term
um can another team have that confidence
in kauai giving him
a long-term deal do you think he stays
in los angeles i do
and i think hawaii you know kawhi's got
an acl injury that's probably going to
keep him out
most if not all of next season
and even if that's the case i do not
foresee the clippers blinking
at giving him a max level extension at
some point i mean kawhi is in a sort of
a similar situation
contractually as chris paul where look
he can opt into that big number 45
48 million dollars whatever it is next
year and then extend it or he can opt
out
and find a five-year deal one way or the
other i think he's gonna do it with the
clippers
i would almost put the house on it i
mean he's he just has the clippers over
the barrel
i mean the clippers gave up everything
to create this roster if kawhi walks
to somewhere else i mean they they don't
have any avenue to to build a winner for
like the next five or six years
because of all the draft picks and young
players they've given away so
yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't count on much
if anything from kawhi
next season but i do expect uh you to
see him
sign some kind of long-term deal with
the clippers before the start of this
one
game six of the nba finals tonight uh
one of the great phrases in all of
sports chris i know game seven gets the
shine but game six is what they rap
about this is the stuff of legends
i feel like i can get in a time machine
and go back to my childhood
what are your earliest memories of the
nba finals of covering the finals
and how have you seen your role change
since those early final
memories uh i mean you're certainly
doing more work i mean
early finals i was more of a fact
checker at side and the reporter
gathering quotes for people like jack
mccallum and ian thompson and all the
other great writers
that came through s i in the early 2000s
um you know the first one i really
thought to write about
on a high level was the boston 08 finals
when they won the championship and i
remember
that game six you know being a
coronation really
i mean that's kind of i have something
of a similar feeling tonight i mean the
celtics
they just smacked around the lakers in
game six of that
series i don't think the lakers yeah i
just think they had given up or they got
they got jumped on early
and then gave up i i can almost see
something similar happening
in this milwaukee series i mean the
bucks have just jumped on phoenix for
these last three games
and and beating them if phoenix gets
down early the bucks are a great home
team
there's going to be such a rabid crowd
there in fyserve um
i can see this game being uncompetitive
non-competitive
in the second half in the same way that
game six of the 2008 finals was
chris as we wrap up here and as the nba
season wraps up you know i get a little
sad
i get a little nostalgic for the season
that just was
but now as basketball fans we're blessed
with social media we can keep tabs on
our favorite players as they go
jumping off yachts around the world they
go on vacation
they go to wineries what's your nba
offseason looking like are you linking
up with magic johnson on the boat with
sam jackson
no they'll be like the nba off season it
isn't very long that's for sure i mean
you you get the free agency on august
2nd you go to summer league on august
9th
uh that wraps probably third week fourth
week third week in august and then
you know for me anyway you're writing
the nba preview issue for the magazine
that comes out in october at that point
so if i get
if i get a week to just shut the phone
off i'll be i'll be a happy camper this
off season well we'll be sure to check
in with you then as always great stuff
thanks so much
chris uh enjoy the games tonight enjoy
the olympics man
all right thanks chris mannix joins the
show sports illustrated the crossover
podcast
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here